y protestas en el campo
protestas en la ciudad y dos gráficas el
tipo de cambio oficial ha llegado a los
130 pesos por dólar mientras la
inflación ha alcanzado el 64 por ciento
los pronósticos indican que podría
llegar al 90 por ciento para diciembre
una caída que se ha acelerado en el
último mes con una devaluación del peso
del 40 por ciento entre las causas
problemas externos como el
fortalecimiento del dólar por la
invasión de rusia a ucrania pero también
estructurales como la escasez de divisas
las expectativas de devaluación el
déficit fiscal y especialmente la
incertidumbre política precisamente el
principal detonante del hundimiento fue
la repentina dimisión el 2 de julio del
ministro de economía martín guzmán quien
era garante del acuerdo de enero para
una reestructuración de la deuda de 44
mil millones de dólares con el fondo
monetario internacional la ocde le daba
entonces un 36 por ciento de crecimiento
el segundo país de américa latina
después de colombia
eran otros tiempos la crisis de gobierno
entre el presidente alberto fernández y
la vicepresidenta cristina fernández
están debilitando la economía argentina
puesto que en la discusión está la forma
de enfrentar la crisis con un
kirchnerismo que se opone al acuerdo con
el fmi
con la confianza por los suelos el
ejecutivo se aferra que quedan entre
13.000 y 18.000 millones de soja de
exportación sin liquidar y a un descenso
del consumo de gas cuando mejoren las
temperaturas en primavera